expect the unexpected mosquitoes
the most mosquitoes i've ever seen
floating down a river getting leeches
face off of you
is not fun
it starts on a pool day it was a friday
i remember like it was yesterday
and i remember thinking this day went so
smoothly like
this is just like wow this friday it's
gonna start my weekend off good
the day was ending the lifeguards were
blowing the whistle for everybody to get
out and we're gonna
we were lining up and we're doing roll i
was counting make sure we had all the
kids
and we were about to get on the bus and
go back to camp when
one of my younger campers uh taps on my
arm
and he's like i need to go to the
bathroom okay let's go
i grab his hand we're scurrying over to
the bathroom
and he suddenly slows down
and he stops and he's like
i don't have to go to the bathroom
anymore and i was like did you have an
accident
and he was like yeah i was like okay
look down he didn't wet his pants i was
like
okay we have a big problem to deal with
here
we panic or i panic so i was like okay
um i guess go into the bathroom close
the door take off your pants
we're gonna throw away your underwear
we'll talk to your parents about this
later it'll be all good he's like okay
so he goes into the bathroom and i hear
this noise
and this poop falls on the ground and
when i tell you it doesn't
mathematically make sense
the size of this poof and the size of
this kid i was like did your
parents feed you a buffet the last three
days and it's just been in there and it
just all
came out right now he like puts his back
back on and he opens the door
and i'm like we can't just leave
because there is a huge like an
adult-sized poop on the ground and i'm
gonna be the last one seen walking out
of here and they are for sure gonna
think it's me
of course this is a pool bathroom and
there's no
paper towels there's only hand dryers
and so i'm like okay toilet seat covers
grab the toilet seat covers
grab like a thick stack and then i grab
his underwear
and i pile those together and grab the
poop if i just like throw it in the
trash i'm like
done and he like looks at me and he's
like don't tell anybody about this i'm
like
trust me dude i don't even know how to
form the words to tell anybody about
this like
his dad shows up and i'm like hey dude
we had a situation with your son and i
tell him what happened
and he says oh yeah
that's been happening recently and i'm
like
expect the unexpected with kids you
never know what's going to happen
and just be ready
our camp is split into different units
we would go on three to four
day camping trips where it would be like
rock climbing canoeing biking hiking on
one of the camping trips that i
mentioned i was on a kunai trip i was in
the back it was me and this other
counselor
with our partners who were campers we
were canoeing and the current was really
strong we were getting pushed like
towards the edge of the river right into
like where this tree had fallen down i
didn't really think anything of it i was
like
but when we get over there we'll we'll
turn and we'll be good
the closer and closer we got the canoe
who was in front of us
waited till like the last minute to get
out of the way of the tree
so my partner and i had no time to turn
and get out of the way so we kind of
went just straight under the tree
so here we are in our canoe like on
in branches basically the canoe with the
other counselor
behind us comes the exact same way that
we did but
we weren't able to move out of the way
because we were stuck in the branch so
we collided
now instead of us colliding where we
were just like bumped
their canoe and the current was so
strong that their canoe came
hit ours and then went under us and
thank god
that we were wearing life jackets but
the counselor and the camper both came
up out of the water like
two to three seconds after and the
counselor turns to me and goes
michael you need to get out of your
canoe something's wrong with my foot
so i jump out of my canoe and i can't
hold on to my canoe
and the branch because the current's so
strong so i looked to my partner
who was a camper and i was like are you
okay with floating down the river by
yourself
she was like yes i'm totally fine and
she's floating away and i'm like
make sure you get some help then i pull
my focus to
my other concert's foot the canoe was
getting pushed by the current
into the counselor's like ankle
basically and then
his ankle was being pushed into the
branch so he was stuck
went underwater felt around and i tried
to push
and every time i did the counselor would
like cry in pain
or wince he was able to kind of wiggle
his foot out while i
pulled the branch away in my head i'm
thinking
oh the other counselors know what's
going on they like called someone to
come help us
so we were sitting there on the branch
for like 30 to 45 minutes
not only did the canoe sink the tree
that we were on
also started sinking i grab onto one of
the branches
the count the camper is grabbing onto my
life jacket
and then my other counselor is grabbing
onto her life jacket
we one by one to kind of like float we
see this
um patch of open sand kind of like
through this
shrub we climb through these like thorny
bushes as if we could it couldn't get
any worse
mosquitoes the most mosquitoes i've ever
seen
and my other counselor decided to go
like a little bit
into the forest to see if he could see
anything he comes back with
so many mosquito bites on his face i was
like we can't stay here any longer
let's just try to float down the river
see if we find anyone
that we know all of us are like linked
arms
and we get back into the water and float
down the river for maybe like
three minutes before we see two heads
coming this way
and it was two of the other counselors
rowing upstream
we finally catch up to them we kind of
like console the camper because
it was kind of a traumatic experience
and then
with the other counselor's phone we call
camp and the counselor and i both
started talking to them and we both
started crying
because we had no time to process what
had just happened to us
looking back on it i think of how lucky
we were that
no one got stuck underwater we were all
wearing life jackets it's kind of like
the scariest and most dangerous
situation i've ever been in
but now it's kind of like well look what
i did like i'm so strong and brave
one summer as a game counselor i went
on a float tubing trip down the river
with my campers
and this is just where you sit in an
inflatable tube float down the river
have a really great time
it's supposed to be really relaxing and
enjoyable and
for the most part it was um but about
halfway through
i was in the back of the herd with some
co-staff of mine who are my really close
friends and i went to scratch my back
and i looked at my hand afterwards and
there was a baby leech on it
so i kind of started to freak out and i
touched my back again
and there were even more baby leeches i
then started crying
and i flipped over onto my stomach and
my friends started gasping and i was
like you need to tell me what is going
on right now
and they like you have baby leeches and
some adult ones
all over your back and so i'm bawling
and thankfully we had a couple of
lifeguards with us that were in kayaks
so i call over
a lifeguard and thankfully he had a
tweezers in his first aid kit
so he pulled those out and i attached my
tube to my friend's tube
and she starts tweezing the leeches off
of me i was crying
in there and then i think oh so
the leeches that are on me are on the
part of my back
that was underwater does that mean that
my butt
also has leeches on them and then i
started crying even more
because i touched my butt and sure
enough there are baby leeches
so while i'm floating down the river
surrounded by campers and all my
co-staff i have to take off
my bathing suit bottoms to get those
leeches off
and my camper is holding my hand while
i'm
sobbing we went on floating down the
river i'm getting trees and finally
my friends don't think they can see
anymore i hang on to the kayak that one
of the lifeguards is in
and she brings me to shore and i get out
my supervisors there and
i was like i need to see a doctor now i
think i have leeches up my butt and
she was like excuse me i was like i
have leeches maybe inside of me and i
start crying again
and so i put on some normal clothes got
in the car and i went back to camp to
see
a doctor i get there and somehow
everyone
at camp has heard about the situation
and i hadn't told anyone
so everyone's coming up to me being like
oh i heard you had 45 leeches on you
what do you mean 45 leeches i didn't
have that many
and they're like oh that's just what i
heard and i come to find out later when
i got back to the campsite where all my
campers and kosaf were saying that
sure enough there were 45 leeches on me
and i just was in
so much of a panic that i had no idea i
finally get to see the doctor
and the cherry on top was that i come to
find out
that the doctor is my camper's dad he
was so nice so helpful
he told me that he had done some
research and that i had probably floated
through
a nest of baby leeches it should be fine
like
they're not harmful so that was really
reassuring
and he told me to take a really good
shower check
the toilet after go to the bathroom and
everything was fine and it turned out
okay
but in that moment it was terrifying and
i've never experienced something like
that
before in my life floating down a river
getting leeches face off of you
is not fun
[Music]
you